britain is still on edge this morning
over prince harry and megan's
extraordinary interview
even after prince william rejected his
sister-in-law's claims of royal racism
it was his first public comment and it's
getting a big thumbs down for many
british people today holly williams is
outside buckingham palace with more on
the story holly good morning to you
good morning the royal family seems to
be trying to minimize the damaging
fallout from this interview
but for some people in this country a
blanket denial of racism like the one
that we heard from prince william
yesterday
just isn't enough harry and megan's
explosive interview has sparked a debate
in this country
about the way in which britain's
powerful tabloid newspapers have covered
the duchess
the first person of color to join the
royal family
but this country is deeply divided a new
poll
found that nearly half of 18 to 24 year
olds
sympathized with harry and megan but
only 9
of the over 65s do and conservative
voters nearly two-thirds of them
sympathize more with the queen in this
crisis than with harry and megan
but the queen isn't just this country's
head of state she's also the head of the
commonwealth
a group of 54 countries most of them
former british colonies
many of their citizens people of color
and some of them are now
saying that the the allegations of
racism have brought back painful
memories
of colonialism gail it has certainly
started a conversation thank you very
much holly williams reporting from
london
and you can watch an encore presentation
of oprah's interview with prince harry
and meghan markle tonight at 8
7 central right here on cbs